c'est une menace qui a fait grand bruit
au sein de l'administration de donald
trump
le président des états unis a dit
vouloir recourir à l'insurrection actes
en d'autres termes déployé l'armée
en riposte aux manifestations qui secoue
les états unis depuis la mort la semaine
dernière d'un homme à foix américain
lors de son interpellation par la police
si une ville ou un état refuse de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
défendre la vie et les biens de ses
habitants alors je déploierai l'armée
des états unis et je résoudrai
rapidement le problème à leur place une
déclaration qui est venu semer le
trouble au sein de la haute hiérarchie
militaire
le secrétaire à la défense marc espère
que donald trump avait lui même placé à
la tête du pentagone s'est opposée à
l'utilisation de la loi de répression
des insurrections le choix d'employer
des forces en service actif dans un rôle
d'application de la loi ne devrait être
fait qu'en dernier ressort et uniquement
pour les situations les plus urgentes et
les plus désastreux nous ne sommes pas
dans une de ces situations actuellement
je ne soutiendrai pas le recours à la
loi contre les insurrections
quelques heures après cette déclaration
c'est au tour de l'ex secrétaire à la
défense james mattis de s'exprimer dans
une tribune publiée par le magazine the
atlantic
l'ancien membre de l'administration
trump avait remis sa démission fin 2018
en raison d'un profond désaccord avec le
président sur le retrait des troupes
américaines du rouillât bas dans le
nord-est syrien
cette nouvelle crise a ravivé les
dissensions entre les deux hommes de mon
vivant donald trump est le premier
président qui n'essaye pas de rassembler
les américains qui ne fait même pas
semblant d'essayer nous assistons
conséquence de trois ans d'absence
délibéré d'efforts en ce sens nous
assistons aux conséquences de trois ans
passés en l'absence d'un gouvernement
responsable
le président américain n'a pas réagi à
la déclaration de l'actuel chef du
pentagone
mais a publié sur twitter des messages
qualifiant james mattis de général le
plus surcoté au monde
donald trump n'aura donc pas recours à
l'armée mais le trouble que son idée
ajouté montre que même avec les membres
les plus fidèles de son entourage le
président américain continue de créer
des désaccords